HIGH.
THE JACKETS SIMILARLY WITH THE
>> PROTECTED NOT PLUCK, GOOD THD
THE PUCK WELL OR NOT.
HE HADUP WITH IT IN THE
CORNER.BEFORE THAT.
NICE JOB BATTLING AND PLAYMAKER.
A COUPLE OF IS JENNER WITH A
ALSO THAT SHOT AS HE'S
FACT-CHECKCK HE WILL HOLD.
AT THE JACKETS ALL AROUND THE
COLORADO GAVRIKOV MAKES A
>> THERE'S A AVALANCHE DEFENDERS
IT BACKND YOU CAN
SEE HERE, HE LOOKS TO HIS
GET BACK.
KUEMPER, HE WILL
HE WAS KNOCKED DOWN.
LINE.VALANCHE NOW UP
TURNING AWAY FROM CHINAKHOV AS A
VISIT BlueJackets.com/HOCKEY
FOR HERERU CAN
THE LEFT WING AT
A GREAT
BACKHANDS ONE AROUND THE WALL.
HE'SP THE
ICE AND CHINAKHOV HIGH IN THEHE.
THE CROWD CHANTINGWORK HARD EVEE
ARE